good please go ahead and go live thank
you
okay
so people joining this live stream sorry
we're starting a bit late we are looking
at machine learning for wolfram language
version 13.
and
uh we had already started on this
haven't we
yes so the new names you see up there
image content detect text content detect
content detector function
okay
and we see these as being
somewhat interim names yes
uh well the the there was a point that
uh
shadi was making to me in the chat that
um
we use i mean the first two
could be interim until we have a final
uh free form content detection that can
work on uh
on multiple uh
on just the
exactly
um the the point that charlie was making
was between content detect and content
detection i don't want to open the
discussion again that the the
[Music]
the main thing was that we typically
called detection with the noun the
function that generates the
uh
exactly the the object yes
like dimensional reduction feature
extraction versus feature extract
dimension now this is wrong this is
wrong we should if if it's called detect
it should be able to have this is just
wrong i mean if if there's an image
there if you can say
image content detect and then you've got
a picture of a piece of fruit
comma these things here
that is a correctly named detect
function
like classify for example that has to
argument form
yeah the the only my only concern with
that is that i'm not sure we want to
encourage the use of it to argument form
because it's so slow
yes and even in future i mean i don't
know like uh
i don't have a super strong opinion i i
tend to think that in the general use
the
the
will it's always been so slow are you
sure we can't make it faster i mean no
no we we we will i think we will in
but it's not going to come immediately
so
[Music]
how slow is it
uh i think that you need at least half
an hour to get uh
some results and uh probably two three
hours to get the
proper thing
this is in general a slow thing like
these fine tunings can take
like a full training can take weeks and
this fight tuning can take uh one one
day if you if you want to do it
so this is not a an interaction so so so
let's change the name
yeah it's the wrong name let's go
we can't deliver yeah
right i mean so if i take this
you're saying
okay let me see what what happens here
i don't understand i told it the time
goal of one minute it's it's the time
goal is basically the
like
try to stop as soon as you can after one
minute and uh
for some stuff it's not really possible
to go as low as one minute so if you say
like five minutes it would probably
manage to what wonder
no this is a transient this is a bug
that we know is it's not affecting the
the result
okay so let's so so this is a very
serious training thing
yeah yeah yeah that the the big
advantage of this is that it's
automating
a whole lot of things that you don't
need to know you don't need to know how
to let me make a suggestion
given how complicated this is maybe we
should call it image content or content
detect train or something like that have
the word train in there
because net train everybody understands
that net training is a is a complicated
process
you know because most of our functions
that are just blah blah blah detect or
whatever
you know
this should have the word training in
there
so
i mean it would usually be because where
would you want to
i don't know
if we can't become very big yes
i know i know i know so let's think
about this
well at least the description should be
train an image content detector yes i
agree with that
isn't it like that already
or no
yeah you're right
but the name should probably be
detection in that you know from that
previously yeah it's crazy too yeah hold
on but i'm still thinking hold on a
second
okay we've got a content detector
function as the output right
that we envision to stay
as a as a name
what the heck is the right way to do
this in terms of parts of speech for
train train image content detector i
mean
look this is way way too slow to be
anything other than a training
i mean
might even be the slowest function in
the system
other than net train perhaps the slowest
function
you know in terms of it minimal use the
basic it might be the slowest basic
example in our examples
is that a possib is that a likely thing
to be the case that could be that could
be okay
it's still saving you days if you don't
want to start from scratch
no it's wonderful it's wonderful i just
want to make sure people understand how
wonderful it is
how slow it is it makes sense it makes
sense
um
okay let me just see what would happen
if we had oh my gosh this is frozen wow
what's going on why is this something
that's really happening
by the way if you if you are bored
during the training you get to see you
got the result out it's just not fully
trained okay okay hold on let me just do
something here
why is this spinning like this there's
some bug in this
oh great
come on
something's very wrong here with this
version somebody um
i'm actually i mean
you you can use the the training image
is a it's not proper but you know i want
to i want to see something really hit
work yeah i'm not i'm not happy with
that
um
web image search
i've got an apple
it from your desk
no
well i'm surprised
that what that it worked yes
it was not nearly enough i mean you
trained this on three images
i know
so it has some augmentation going on
inside of course that's uh well
otherwise it wouldn't be
yeah this is probably too small you can
do a septum threshold a very low number
and see if it was actually getting hints
at that
so why can't i tell this thing like i'm
really sure there's one of those things
i mean can i tell it surely it makes a
difference whether it's like i'm really
sure there's an apple and orange or a
banana in this picture
now just tell me which one versus free
form you know
is it you know is there anything like
this in there
i mean it's something that you can build
using this function yeah
oh but but i'm asking i'm asking the
question why not wouldn't it be when you
tell that function
um i'm not sure i mentioned one of the
big problems here is the localization
like uh you still needs a lot a lot of
information a lot of training to to find
objects by the way is that there's no
possibility of a training panel that
shows losses going down and so on
yeah yeah sure i i plan to like if you
if you do
dollar debug mode true which is a bit
hacky at the moment you can enable a lot
more reporting and uh one thing
i'm planning is to
if we can have a double panel like we
can have a netrain the netrain panel
explicitly shown
you know i have to say i favor the name
train image content detector
i know it's long and ponderous but it
says what it does
and by the time you've got this amount
of time necessary to do it i just don't
think it's right to pretend you know
because otherwise then somebody when
they see anomaly detection
or feature extraction they're going to
think oh my gosh that's going to take
seven hours as well yeah no no i
understand the point yes and and
hopefully we can go back to just content
detection when we have uh a much faster
way to define tuning that's what i think
we should do train image content
detector train
text content detector
okay
sounds good
all right let me just look at um
uh
you know mark on livestream is content
detector train yeah the problem with
that is we have to say image content
detector train i think it's better to
say train i think this is such a you
know this is i mean as i say as the
function with the longest
um it needs a long name because it's
this long function yeah well right
progress reporting does that work yet
the progress reporting thing
uh
yeah there should be two folds you if
you say false it doesn't do it i say i
say i say okay so
okay well great
all right should we go on here i think
yeah yeah yeah please okay what was next
for us to look at
uh so this you map is nice uh
i think you might
you want to be aware of this because
it's a new uh dimension action method
that means that it can be used to make a
different speed video space plot we have
a
documentation page for the method
and that's nice but i mean if it will it
be used by default or not
we we are we are actually aiming for for
that it's um it
produces more cluster data on average
so it's um
compared to disney is or disney i don't
know how you pronounce that
it clusters a bit more and for for many
features can be faster like uh
jerome is working hard on making this as
optimal as possible and it's already
as fast if not faster than disney okay
so i can say feature space plot
of that method arrow you map is that
correct
it was working on two days ago i tried
this on today and it was failing let's
let's hope that your works by the way
for feature space plot please do make
sure i mean these these particular
things like here these are graphics and
they have to be rasterized and so on and
for some reason it's something is
happening very very slowly
well rasterize is slow in general
yeah it's oh okay anyway
i i'm working
i've been working to make rasterize
faster for like three years
so the the kernel side of it is in
general uh uh so do you think that's
different from the tsne result
it should be if you if you look at the
at the documentation page uh it's on our
example data sets it's it's very clear
you can uh use uh
i don't know if jerome did it in future
space plot but that dimension reduce has
the u-map link
dimension reduction actually is a main
function
there are method options here
yeah if you scroll down there should be
yeah there it is future view map
so for example if you click on so so do
these all have separate documentation
pages yeah
you know what i think that we should put
a thing up here
saying yeah no no absolutely
i i started doing some some knitting for
um for neural networks uh i didn't have
time to do machine learning but there
are a lot of these that okay fine but i
think we should put it up there and we
should have a guide page which includes
like these pictures or some version of
these some idealized version of these
pictures
yep
because that's what i want to pick from
you know yeah no no it makes a lot of
sense it makes a lot of sense and
actually when we do
webinars we basically build the grid
with those pictures
right
by the way i hope and we have friends
and and why isn't that in the page
itself the reference page itself why
don't we have a visual picker
if that's what you want to use to pick
method from
yeah why not right there with the
methods
yeah
exactly a three column
oh yeah absolutely yeah we're doing that
in
many other cases so exactly good idea
okay so question for this
um
there have been some issues the feature
space plot about when it actually plots
the points versus the images etc has
that been fixed or not yet
uh
we open a bunch of bugs uh
that
we are basically only providing the the
algorithmical background for this uh i
had some talks with brett to to do a
round of updates uh we should probably
do another one uh i know i know
sometimes because it was really it's
kind of non-functional
but
can you push that and if i need to get
involved i will no i don't think it
would be needed i mean we we are some
stuff has been tracked sometimes it's
been fixed already so
okay
okay
so decision tree is an oh as a tree
expression
cool yeah we look at this we look at
this last time
we are adding this uh we i don't think
we want to document this this round
because we are not super happy about the
fact that uh
we discussed this last time like we the
the the decision tree is splitting on uh
pre-processed data
and actually roger forwarded me some
emails with users that
agree with me and think that is still
useful
because you can train we can have
examples where you train uh
trees with minimal pre-processing but in
general we want a more
global approach where you can always
have a decision tree uh train on the
side of the classifier that can explain
it basically so it's kind of a
pre-pre-step for for that
i don't think i have some notebooks but
i don't think i have anything shareable
right now so i would if you go ahead i
will i will look for it and i can send
you an example
okay
randomness
that's very good that's very good that's
an important thing this this was a pain
it's still a pain it's not completely
solved because there's some stuff that
is completely ingrained in the framework
and
we have only
limited a lot of time for refactoring
but
it's already much better than before and
it was a much requested feature
by internal external people customers to
have it always
reproducible
yeah there's some internal and then
change of libraries
oh that's good
progress framework okay nut encoder
save definitions what's that for
um
we use i mean by default we use it to
manipulate or stuff like that just to
embed to serialize the definition of
functions in cells so you don't have to
to have a color running where you like
you don't have to have a definition
running
when you run the manipulate
this has a problem what manipulates i
don't understand so if you if you if you
run and manipulate when you say like uh
i don't know uh x equal five and you
plot uh between zero and x
and then you close and you reopen a
notebook with a new kernel sure i
understand what save definition does in
general what's the relationship okay in
this case the point is that you could
have net encoder function
comma f
and if if you don't have f uh
like the version before it was telling
you oh this relies on some external
definition so you have to use explicit
functions like functions actually i
understand i understand so it's the same
the point is this is analogous to
manipulate that net encoder
has a dependence on an external function
and you're making sure that the that the
actual net encoder symbolic expression
contains the definition of that function
exactly exactly
okay this way you can add it to a
network save it in a network file and
when you import it you will have it you
don't need to pass around definitions
what is this net i mean net graph adding
new ports to an existing graph at any
level
oh uh we did a complete
revamp on the port syntax it was like a
some stuff you couldn't do before
right now have we have we reviewed that
what that enforced the port syntax oh no
sorry sorry sorry the the worst syntax
is the same it's just that some stuff
use that
for example you
you couldn't uh connect
like a nested container inside to some
other container in some other place you
had to be always at the same top level
now it's it's a lot more
right i mean all this stuff i have to
say
is you know eventually
you know
this is kind of i mean
well i don't know i don't know this is
block diagrams versus versus code
basically i mean we've got to i know we
had the discussion many many times the
the end the end game is not going to be
this one i agree with you
yeah
but for the time being let's make it as
pleasant as possible too oh i agree it's
it's already pretty nice to work with
yeah it's great
join chains with single input or single
output graphs okay fine
that's a big deal isn't it supposed to
automatic differentiation and compiled
layer
yeah now is it being enabled by default
so you don't need to provide separately
the forward and backward pass you can
only provide forward pass and if we can
differentiate it we will do that
otherwise
okay
one second
okay
so let me just see how this works
oh boy
so this is really using the compiler
yeah
yeah also using the compiler to do the
automatic differentiation
so this is not a
simple end user type thing this is
pretty serious stuff
now basically this is if you want to
write your own if you have a compile
function and you want to use it uh
to train a network is
so we're saying you're saying that all
functions that are compilable are also
defined shapeable is that a true
statement
um
no no no no we have we have an automatic
uh differentiation engine in the
compiler that can fail
so
for example if i have a bessel function
in the compiler can i differentiate it
yes
but i don't think we do have it in the
compiler
okay but a sine function we do yes yes
yes
more interestingly
array functions
linear algebra functions
like fold is fold differentiable
don't know but in principle it should be
because that's just there's a default
list here which i think is more
obviously differentiable than unfold
yeah i don't know i think it should be
because it's just a loop
you know and loops are differentiable
for sure
right
okay
anyway this is i have to say it's been a
very nice interaction with the compiler
team i think it was good for for both
the two who is the whole main who has
been the main
what what is the main axis of
interaction now
rob yep
okay
yeah i mean rob is the one that's done
the automatic differentiation there okay
and we're gonna bring it out more
broadly but not cool we could couldn't
make it for this release but
i wonder whether automatic
differentiation has uses outside of
machine learning
of course it does it came up with
optimization and it's used in
optimization and in machine learning
it's used for optimization
yeah but even beyond that
if we could take a symbolic expression
and differentiate it
a program and differentiate it
yes interesting concept i mean i i'm
wondering what else
you know there must be sensitivity
analysis for numerical precision and
things like that we could do with that
yes
most sensitive yes
true
we can do that just for a program but if
you think of a solver
the way we compute sensitivity is
usually done a little bit differently
actually we do use when i think about it
we do use automatic differentiation for
some of that
i would think so we use symbolic
differentiation on on actual expressions
i would think
no
uh
well it's a complicated story it would
be better if rob is here actually okay
all right fine okay
okay
um
x new models what is x well like
at the time we wrote this we didn't know
what x was going to be
it's going to be like around five six
okay
for video cool yeah and and right now i
mean the neural net repository seems to
be just working well there's you know
it's just like it's a good medium we put
things in it and it just works right
yeah it is i mean
we are smoothing out a lot of things and
is actually
a good testing ground for our onyx
import export
okay and uh
and it keeps us focused on the kind of
modern architectures and stuff so
all right let's talk about text
translation so this is now a built-in
text translation is that what you're
telling me
no no it's not it's not there yet this
is there was a note here i mean the
point is that we we have a function
ready uh
i need to
to talk to christian to integrate this
in text translation you you're not going
to find in the prototype
the the reason is that it required
serious work on the resource system
to handle massive
massive models
and it just recently got merged like
recently
all right but but the goal here is to
have text translation
be something that does not require any
api access
exactly
i mean our api i guess
on people's computers etc right yeah
yeah and actually we have the you had
the idea when we first brought it up and
uh this is on track as i don't think has
been merged yet in the resource
framework but has been worked on to have
a synchronous download of resources so
the the end game could be that you run
text translation on a string
it sends that to the cloud
and it starts downloading the network so
until the network is is there you can
have limited access using the cloud okay
at a lower low rate yeah and then you
have it locally and then that's much
faster and you can do whatever you want
that's good that's a good idea it sounds
like it was my idea so whatever i told
you it was your idea yeah right
um
i'm not not claiming it was mine right
by the way here's a question
our
um
speech recognize does it work in
languages other than english
no
uh
i think that we could in principle i
mean i think that there are other like
chinese for instance
what about spanish
don't know
i think it was very limited in other
chinese for sure
well has been trained on chinese as well
i was dictatorizer or you you are saying
that there's we have
the underlying i think
i think we should have a look given that
we're now having local text translation
we should have a look
at um
uh
you know what's possible with speech
recognized for other languages
right
um okay well good stuff um
livestream asks about welcome language
documentation for time complexity
most of our functions it's way too
complicated to say the place where that
is well documented is in look at all
this lovely stuff in fact i want to look
at this documentation right now myself
um
in data structures is this going to have
the trees in it
here
there's the time complexity
for stuff like this for these for these
very well defined lower level things we
absolutely have time complexity
estimates
but for something like text translation
it's
meaningless
way too complicated
um
all right anything else we should cover
in this meeting
i think that's it
okay excellent um there was a lot of
work that went into getting mxnet to a
new i'm sure forum so that uh and that
now works on the apple and native
silicon stuff
yeah we have a native field for for that
one thing we can quickly look at i don't
know if you if you care about like there
was uh you open the documentation page
for net unfold this is a new symbol that
we want to add
okay
but it doesn't it has no sense of
this is the inver is it in fact the
inverse of fold
is the inverse of the net
fold operator
is not strictly speaking the inverse of
a fold function
right it sort of picks out the you see
that that chord there that's like the f
the f
yeah like you have you have fold f and
this takes out the the f except that it
is not not as as clear in many networks
you know it isn't uh
like like in full depth so so i mean the
analogy analogy would be
if i take um this one has more like a
systems definition see it has an f and a
g there's an output equation too
see our
i mean you could have that sort of you
could just have a more complicated sort
of f and you can have an output but
normally you separate the two if you see
that below the picture
yeah equation that the z the state
update and then there's the output
equation for the g
right
i mean here
we would normally say differences
to get i mean if if f was plus
the unfold of this would be differences
but you want f as a net you want f as an
operator i i i know i know i know i'm
i'm i'm trying to understand is there a
um uh
look you see that yeah yeah yeah i mean
that's getting back the data
but but the whole point is what you're
doing here is
you know
what is twofold
to to foldless with plus differences is
the unfolder of fold list with plus
the question is is there a general
unfolder for fold list with f's
i don't think so but no i i don't think
there is either because i think that's a
special thing for a neural net like that
is a way of of munging the f
to get you yeah i understand what this
is doing it makes it you don't even look
at the data like you you know your fault
list plus as a symbolic uh folder and
you say how can i get it out and this is
very useful for many
nlp applications because you want to use
that f to
generate text sequences mainly
sounds good
all right we should we should wrap it up
here and um
uh i don't know i think roger i think
you're involved in the multi-computation
language design at the top of the next
hour right i didn't it's not on my
calendar oh no
really
well that's like crazy
you should be in that okay
it's at the top of the next hour i'll
just have someone send me a calendar and
i'll be there
or send me some place to go i can go
there
right and well yeah yeah yeah they'll
they know they'll do it okay well good
stuff very nice well good work and um
uh until
until the next